Silicon Valley Bank 16 biggest bank in
America with over 200 billion dollars in
assets goes belly up with people making
a run on the bank everybody's panicking
what's going to happen if this goes on
to other Banks one side of the hour send
we got to bail them out we can't let
them go now these are billionaires oh
yeah you want to have capitalism for the
rest of us but socialism for the rich
this is exactly why Bernie Sanders was
right they're doing the same thing they
did to actually no it's a very different
how is it different lots of questions
we're going to cover all of that in
today's show
[Music]
so if you get value from the video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel to fully understand what's going
on with this you have to put a different
lens on to understand different people's
perspective meaning when Benghazi
happened most people have forgotten
about Benghazi the only people that are
still thinking about Benghazi on a
regular basis are those who lost a
family member one of the four family
members are thinking about it till today
why because it was a direct impact of
pain to you Silicon Valley Bank there's
different people there those who work
for Silicon Valley as an employee well
they're going to take a hit those who
own shares in Silicon Valley Bank they
were owners they're going to take a hit
there are those that have 250 000 or
less with Silicon Valley Bank they'll be
protected by FDIC but then there's those
that have over 250 000 they're not
protected by the FDIC and then outside
of that you have those who have their
business accounts with them that are
trying to make payroll they don't know
how to make payroll next thing you know
all these employees at these startups
are sitting there saying how am I going
to pay my salary and last but not least
they're Outsiders me and you you ain't
got shares I ain't got shares if you
don't we're kind of sitting here saying
they should do this and they should do
that but you gotta look at it from
different people's lives now having said
that let's get right into it so what is
the biggest fear of people saying we got
to go bail them out and what is the
people on this side saying this is just
like AIG here's the difference in 2008
the government bailed out the company
AIG in 2023 FDIC is bailing out they're
calling it a backstop they're bailing
out the depositors not the company the
companies being bought out different
divisions of it different people are
buying the UK Division I think was
bought by HSBC for a pound one pound not
a billion pounds one pound Apollo is
buying a loan debt this guy's buying
this that guy's behind us and at the
same time they're doing that so the
bailout isn't for the company to still
be around because the CEO the CFO those
guys mismanaged the bank a matter of
fact the CEO he goes to Europe to go get
a trip for Bank of the Year award or
something like that while Forbes
Magazine calls them one of the best
banks of the year and they retweet it
five days before they go belly up and he
comes back realizes what's going on
takes three and a half million dollars
or so of his stocks and sells then the
CMO sells it all these CFO sells it
they're selling shares known this
company is going to go bankrupt and
they're giving bonuses out 12 days
before the company going bankrupt they
know this is coming that's called front
running the fed's gonna go do something
about that the government's going to do
something about that they should be held
accountable but the depositors know now
there's some people that say taxpayers
are not going to pay anything for that
you're going to be paying for something
for that the FDIC doesn't print money to
pay things out and if they do you and I
are still paying for it so no that is
coming from us to pay for that the
problem is the following that's the part
that everybody has been thinking about
the FDIC today if you looked at their
balance sheet they have roughly
125 billion dollars in their account 125
billion dollars if you know how much
money they're trying to insure with that
125 billion dollars you ready 9.9
trillion dollars of deposits did you
hear me take out 125 billion dollars to
protect 9.9 trillion dollars of deposits
so what's the fear if FDIC goes and says
we're going to go above the usual 250
and we're going to build these other
depositors out and we're going to take
care of them what becomes a problem if
all of a sudden Jerome Powell increases
rates and other Banks can't make their
payments on their bond and there's a run
on different banks what happens all of a
sudden the 27 Regional banks that we
have now it's 26 because one of them is
SV Bank the 2250 Community Banks that we
have in cities are 50 000 or less
everybody is going to start panicking
saying hey babe we got to take the money
out we got to go to a big Bank let's go
to Chase as a matter of fact just in the
last week Jamie dimon CEO of Chase you
know what they did they got nearly two
billion dollars of clients that were
with Silicon Valley Bank why because
their Brokers kept calling calling
calling that's capitalism competition
that's when the fear becomes from having
all these different banks to go into
five then you and I don't have a lot of
competition we lose that's the people
who are saying that's bail out the
depositors but if they do it once maybe
twice maybe three times they can't do it
if this happens to 510 other Banks then
they have to go back to printing of
money again which is going back to the
mistakes we made in 08 which is
quantitative easy that's what they're
trying to prevent from happening having
said that where does capitalism get a
black eye a couple different places
crony capitalism which you need policy
officials to help you Monopoly where you
control a production of a product
monopsony which is when you are the
controlling the buyer of a product
you're like the only guy that buys a
product and you have control over it I'm
the only guy that buys it you can't get
the product so you can bully all the
other people that want to get it that's
a form of a monopoly then sometimes the
inherited wealth folks are getting yeah
well I can't believe you got your money
you didn't have to earn four you don't
have to do this it doesn't matter their
parents worked hard and they want to
pass it down to their kids you ought to
do the same to pass the money to your
kids as well there's nothing wrong with
that but there's one part that deserves
criticism and here's where it is the
four Foundation of capitalism this is
what it is it's a freedom to buy freedom
to sell freedom to try and freedom to
fail there are crybaby capitalists who
want to take the risk to make a lot of
money but they don't want to fail you
can't do that so you want to put all
your money into this investment or a
opportunity and you wanted to go to
whatever the amount is but if all of a
sudden God forbid hits the fan you
want to make sure the government comes
and bails you up those capitalists I
call the crybaby capitalist those are
the ones that that make the other
capitalists who do it the right way get
criticism FYI this isn't only in a place
like this this happens to a lot of
different people the same way O.J
Simpson got a lot of hate when people
said we all know this guy's guilty a lot
of people in America think he was guilty
how the hell does this happen it's just
because he's a celebrity some people
will write it happened because he was a
celebrity some people may say he could
afford better attorneys some people say
if it was an average person who did this
you know he'd be going to jail for Life
how can this happen to OJ these are all
valid questions to be asking but when an
event like this happens with Silicon
Valley Bank rather than jumping out
there and saying let's do another Occupy
Wall Street Chapel is suck billionaire
suck
for every one stupid thing a capitalist
does they've done 99 other things such
as the platform you're holding your hand
in right now to watch this video your
phone and the service and the company
with the phone and all the other stuff
all of that was started by capitalist
all the equipment here was started by
capitalists there's a lot of good
capitalists do but every once in a while
they do horrible things just like
everybody else that doesn't mean we
should judge them as all the other 99 of
capitalists that do the right thing if
you got value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel I
also did a video I think five years ago
titled 10 reasons why I love capitalism
if you've never seen it click here to
watch it take care everybody bye-bye
foreign